I don't care about hey I just care about
being able to actually breathe up there
pink practicing her signature aerial
stunts man she does not mess around for
the American Music Awards this coming up
Sunday she's opening the show with Kelly
Clarkson come on oh that's a serious
girlfriend right there two of my
absolute favorites another two of my
favorites that are gonna be there medium
we're gonna be all over that red carpet
and moolah pink is hoping her
performance isn't beautifully traumatic
you have to up the ante here you have to
the older I get the the more dangerous
it becomes this is by far the craziest
most insane thing I've ever attempted to
do a rehearsal to rappel down the side
of a building
if so pink will clearly raise the
aerialist bar if I don't do it now this
time your height of it this is the first
time that I've ever panicked pink as
usual not only tops herself but I think
what can happen in a musical performance
a maze hosts presea Ellis Ross is
already on pins and needles for the pink
performance which will air live on ABC
we were with a blackish star for the red
carpet rollout in between yesterday's
rehearsal
we also got a peek at the seating cards
in place pink is just two seats away
from Kelly Clarkson and not far apart
demi lovato next to Nick Jonas while one
row down Selena Gomez so could one of
those seats be for the beads
incidentally Selena will also perform
and debut her new music video wolves
during the broadcast I'm blocking out my
new one
Tracy will navigate a lot of moving
parts from her numerous costume changes
to keeping the flow in between the 18
performances and more than 30 presenters
taking the stand I'll probably be
nervous right before but as my mother
says nervousness and excitement are very
similar feelings just with a different
label
there you go listen mom knows best Tracy
will be among the presenters when her
legendary mother Diana Ross receives a
Lifetime Achievement Award the show airs
live this Sunday on ABC so good
[Music]
you